rihanna makes tarjay her runway picking
out clothes for her baby but you are
making it look so stylish
well you have to that's the mama to be
enjoying a little shopping spree rocking
a blue hoodie that says living the dream
with the new york skyline repairs the
look with a sparkly faux leather
miniskirt and pair of metallic purple
heels
the singer who's expecting her first
child with asap rocky was browsing the
aisles picking up clothes onesies and
socks for her little one she may never
wear it but she save it so our babies
will be flyer than their parents and of
course fans want to know was re-shopping
for a boy or a girl well the beauty
mogul did place a small orange dress
into her cart but also made sure to get
some boy items as well all to avoid an
accidental gender reveal it was fun now
the bb pump might be covered up on this
outing but the grammy winner's been
proudly showing it off with some other
fierce outfits like this silver moment
at her fenty beauty launch event in los
angeles rhys stunned in a coperny custom
crop top and long skirt as she put her
belly on full display i couldn't tell
you how happy i am and the umbrella
singer's been serving high fashion looks
since announcing in january that she's
expecting it's a long nine to ten months
girl you know you you have to enjoy it
last month when e.t caught up with
rihanna she opened up about having fun
with her looks i'm trying to enjoy it as
much as i could and fashion is one of my
favorite things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend and soon ri and asap will
officially be mom and dad last month the
source told e.t the couple is so happy
about starting their family adding that
rihanna has always wanted to be a mother
and have children and she thinks asap is
going to be the best dad i'm just
excited for what i don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited and turns out riri
is taking notes on parenting techniques
specifically from some of the real
housewives everyone just wants to be
loved and accepted at the base minimum
it's what your parents should be doing
for you in a new interview with elle
magazine the superstar reveals that she
admires the chic parenting style of
orange county's heather dubrow and the
way she just allows her kids to be who
they are yes i'm sort of like a
controlling person but as i'm getting
older i've learned to let it go a little
bit and try to go with the flow faree
thinks she'll probably be more like new
jersey's theresa judice that's nothing
compared to just being there for them
you know you're their mommy or their
provider you're you're their everything
theresa from jersey does not play about
her kids she will flatten you about
those kids and that resonates with me a
lot quite simply ree says you talk about
my kids it's over i'm looking forward to
it until the little one arrives we'll
just be over here admiring me's
impeccable style
[Music]
you